alles sitzt wegen gerade mitten in
berlin genauer gesagt in berlin mitte
und hier habe ich direkt um die ecke
hotel gebucht und zwar 1 kapsel hotel da
habe ich glaube ich heute nacht einfach
nur eine kapsel in der schlafen muss das
gut ist aber das ganze extrem günstig
nur 29 euro und ich dachte mir das muss
ja mal testen weil ich musste ihn nach
berlin janetzko da gehen wir jetzt mal
ein solches gehabt ich bin mittlerweile
schon außenmantel wieder raus und im
monte machen jetzt hier für heute nacht
genau ihr werdet euch manchmal hier
sehen wenn ich irgendwas zu melden habe
hier ist auf jeden fall gut action mit
einem zentrum für 29 euro da kann man
nicht mehr kann ok ich werde
wahrscheinlich nicht mal ein fenster das
gleiche das dann wieder aus ich hoffe
mal ich finde das jetzt warte man
also hier muss es eigentlich sein
46 ist das moment okay leute ich bin
schon zu weit das ist dann im gebäude
hinter mir hier ist ein lidl drin aber
da hier nach da stets ja
weisheit sogar mit rolltreppe die
funktioniert noch nicht perfekt
hey ich muss sagen der erste eindruck
als ich da rein gekommen bin war
eigentlich ganz gut also erst dachte ich
okay wo ist das jetzt dann hat die
rolltreppe auch nicht funktioniert
daneben waren lidl aber man wenn man so
drauf geachtet man kann schon finden
vielleicht kann man das ganze noch ein
bisschen besser ausschildern weil das
ist wirklich schon versteckt auf jeden
fall ging ja dann diese schwarze tür auf
und dahinter war sonja wirklich es wirkt
auf den ersten eindruck die sonne
raumstation weil diese kapseln alles
leuchte zu blau das war wirklich sehr
verrückt der typ einer rezeption
supernett der hat sich bestimmt war zehn
minuten für mich zeit genommen hat mir
alles gezeigt ein bisschen das konzept
erklärt hat ein zimmer reserviert oder
was heißt ein zimmer er seine kapseln
dankeschön wie lang gibson das schon
hier
wohl das irgendwie
ja nur eine nacht genau
okay auch nämlich unten muss ich nicht
klettern dann je 26
anders klang und licht und so ist drin
super
in chisinau alles klar dankeschön
wissen dass hier auch für leute alles
blau wir gehen mal rein in die kapsel
aber ich stelle mal kurz die auf dem
boden der ja hier gar nicht rein
aha und
was sagst du so kapsel
mal gucken ob ich hier in der nacht
aushalten weil ich habe ja nicht mal ein
fenster und hat hierzu überhaupt
alter
leute ich komme gar nicht klar ich liebe
es hier mitten in berlin hingegen seiner
kapsel ich habe gar keine fragen wer
rechts neben mir liegt wer links neben
mir liegt und jetzt also muss sagen für
29 euro ist es natürlich extrem günstig
aber auch irgendwie schon dann
vielleicht doch teuer weil du hast hier
kaum platz du hast nicht mein fenster
ich zeige euch erstmal die kapsel wir
sind ja gerade rein gekommen was ich
ganz cool finde die haben ja sogar
handtücher damit habe ich nicht
gerechnet damit kann ich die
gemeinschaft später gehen dann seht ihr
mich hier im spiegel alu hier haben wir
dann so ein ich weiß hier kann man sich
wahrscheinlich sogar ein wecker stellen
wir haben wir die uhrzeit so und ich
kann hier sogar eine klimaanlage
anmachen krass hier kann ich mein handy
laden auch nicht schlecht und jetzt habe
ich sogar noch mehr licht
ja gut für leute die klaustrophobie
haben ist das hier auf jeden fall nichts
aber gut es sich das nicht auch und hier
ist noch ein tisch mit der stoff ja
schon erklärt
da kann ich dann theoretisch sogar noch
hier drin arbeiten nach unten save a ja
und jetzt hat auch schon gesehen wir
haben ja so spende ist dass die mehrzahl
von spinnen spinnt spinde spinnst du
halt wie im schwimmbad wo man seine
sachen verstauen kann und hier schlafe
ich jetzt einfach nachts ich komme
darauf immer noch nicht klar bettdecke
und so was alles schon bezogen bin
gespannt wie die nacht wird und ob ich
hier ein erholsamer schlaf habe aber ich
muss jetzt erst mal gleich hier raus
weil ich will auf jeden fall noch was
von berlin sehen ich habe ein paar
termine und ich weiß noch gar nicht wo
ich mich umziehen soll leute ihr werdet
von mir hören hoffe ich möchte jetzt
erstmal die toiletten ab aber ich muss
wissen
wenn ich gut aus hier keine duschen kann
man es heftig nach pisse die ja
also ich wäre es nicht schlecht nur so
aber das ist nicht so so fertig
gepinkelt das hier ist die dusche so
sieht eigentlich ganz gut wenn sie nicht
so riechen würde eben eine sache die ich
mal kurz an sprechen wollte vielleicht
hat er jetzt vergessen eine rezeption
hat musste kein cooler nachweis
abliefern das nicht schon deswegen kraft
will hier ist ja alles wirklich sehr
engen raum ich bin echt gespannt wie das
wird immer so der korona sache muss ich
sagen der hat mich dann noch im
nachhinein als ich raus sagen gefragt
weil das wohl vergessen hatte oder so
keine ahnung da habe ich ihm dann halt
gezeigt deswegen da muss ich mich noch
mal korrigieren also was mir nie regiert
schon auffällt ich habe mir die tür zu
und hier wird irgendwo gesagt es ist
sehr hellhörig nenne ich habe mir die
tür zu
ich glaube es geht horner naja
[Musik]
heute ausgeht ich werde sogar noch in
berlin unterwegs war ein bisschen wie
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt ich bin jetzt
auf jeden fall wieder hier in einer
kapsel ich habe von über geräuschen also
überall bewegen sich im menschen also es
ist so krank hellhörig wm ist halb zwölf
ist jetzt bin ich hoffe dass ich mich
hier ein bisschen erholen kann ich
habe einmal in einem zimmer ohne fenster
geschlafen das war der horror ich weiß
ja wie das kennt oder schon mal gemacht
habe ich weiß
ich werde das schon überstehen aber du
merkst ja gar nicht wenn es hell wird
oder hier ist es ja komplett dunkel rund
um die uhr in diesem cup das habe ich
schon ich bin durch eine gute nacht nun
bringt das nicht aus
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ich bin seit einer
stunde oder so einfach nur noch ich
finde es wirklich der horror seit einer
stunde stehen hier durchgehend irgendwo
menschen auf was ja auch normal ist
wobei so normal vielleicht auch nicht
543 keine ahnung was sie machen man hört
halt alles und ich kann absolut nicht
mehr peinlich finde die luft hier drin
auch grausam deswegen ist mein plant
jetzt fläche aus zu checken und früh
stimmen zu gehen und dann war das meine
erfahrung aber ich weiß nicht so ganz
ich werde mich auf jeden fall durch
nochmal sehen ihr habt gesehen oder ich
glaube gemerkt so besonders gut schlafen
darin konnte ich irgendwie nicht das
problem war einfach also das bett an
sich ist bequem du kannst dich da gut
hinlegen du hast auch an sich genug
platz für dich selber und das ist gar
nicht das problem nur diese katzen so
extrem hellhörig also du hast alles was
innen kapseln um dich herum passiert du
hörst wenn leute auf schon da ist wenn
leute reden du hast wenn gesagt wird
sowieso was natürlich und bei mir war
nicht mehr alles voll wenn alles voll
ist ist das glaube ich schon irgendwie
schwer da gut erholsam zu schlafen werde
zumindest mein eindruck obwohl ich das
konzept eigentlich ganz cool finde ich
meine wir sind mitten in berlin man
bezahlt echt nicht so viel geld zu tun
ist wenn man alleine reist klar du hast
auch kaum platz es ist alles sehr
minimalistisch gehalten ja deswegen wenn
man halt nicht viel geld ausgeben will
ob man jetzt in einem hostel schläft
vielleicht sich da das zimmer teilt oder
seine eigene kapsel hat muss jeder
selber wissen ich für mich hab trotzdem
lieber mein eigenes zimmer auch wenn ich
dann vielleicht noch mal 20 30 euro mehr
bezahlen aber das geht auch du christ
auch in berlin für 50 setzte ein
vernünftiges halbwegs vernünftiges
hotelzimmer da wollte ich nämlich noch
zu sagen weil man eine doppel kapsel
bucht dann zahlt man 58 euro also 29
euro x 2 und da ist es dann meine
meinung nach wirklich so würde ich
niemals bezahlen dann gehe ich halt
lieber in einem drei sterne hotel oder
so die doppel kapsel war am eingang und
da waren halt einige leute die da
gespielt haben hatten halt die tür dann
so oft du hast null privatsphäre du hast
gemeinschaft weder also keine ahnung das
würde ich niemals dafür ausgeben
trotzdem was so lustig erfahrung ich
hoffe euch hat das video auch gefallen
und für mich geht's morgen ins best
hotel in berlin da freue ich mich schon
drauf insider dazu wird aber nicht sagen
kann
drei leute und schreibt gern noch
weitere sachen in die kommentare die ich
mal testen sollte gerne irgendwie sowas
auch in die richtung haut rein